Tesla's in Santa Rosa California
Merry Christmas Tessa how are you Oh
Merry Christmas Dave thank you for
taking my call sure I have been
listening to you like crazy these last
couple weeks my girlfriend of mine
mentioned your name
and I was super curious and I want my
husband and I to have financial freedom
we have a big pile of debt part of its
my student loans for my master's degree
Chuck payment a fifth wheel that we
don't even have in the state with us
because we moved from place to place
it's really a sore spot for me and I'm
suddenly I have a really special gift
from someone that I lost a couple years
ago I received $50,000 and I'm listening
to you it seems that once we have that
little bit of savings in place to use
excess savings to pay off debt is our
next step but I'm I'm struggling with
coming to terms with that because I feel
like using it on stupid things that are
so not important and that person was so
important to me is not the right thing
to do
what would be the stupid thing you'd be
using you know credit card debt you know
my husband's decisions to buy things
that you know we didn't need at the time
before we were married
I'm very conservative on spending he is
not and it some things you know I've
been working through and I it's a
challenging conversation with him and I
you know I ordered your book I'm so
excited to get it and trying to get him
to just be on the same page with me and
he says it is and wants to work towards
this because I know he wants you know
our future to look better than what it
is until he's willing to sell the fifth
wheel and maybe the truck I would not do
this okay because I don't need his words
on his actions I know how I feel it I
come to terms with thinking about taking
20 thousand to pay off the four big
credit cards that we have and one is
mine and I you know you're trying to
halfway do something see the problem is
not the debt and the problem is not the
gift using the gift to pay off the debt
the problem is you can't see a future
where your husband is not going to
repeat the stupidity and you need to
have that future cleared up and the
futures cleared up when we know he has
transformed his heart and has become a
grown-up and has quit buying toys that
he can't afford I did that when I was a
quote grown man I was a little boy
buying toys I couldn't afford and so I
know who he is I know this guy he likes
stuff he likes trucks and things to pull
buying the trucks and all the so night
soon he needs to sell out crap